Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
There's a narration on the authority of
One of the 10
one of the 10 companions
that were
earmarked
given
the news that they are members of the
people of paradise for certain.
the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam's maternal uncle from his
mother's side
whom the prophet sallallaii wasallam was
narrated to have said
this is my uncle who else has an uncle
mine
narrates writes a narration that's
it really shows us where the minds of
the companions
were were
when it comes to a then making a then
it's only one person
or at most two
that get the reward for a then
this is a huge reward report.
Especially in the time of the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam and the
companions,
people are praying, fasting, breaking
their fast, coming to prayer all based
on the muadins
alert to them.
And for this reason, the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam said,
He said the people who make adan
the
it's not just a person who makes then
it's the person who is the
they are the people who have the longest
necks on the day of judgment.
What does that mean long neck?
Sometimes a person may imagine that this
means that they're going to have
long physical necks. No, what's meant by
this is this is a way that
the Arabs spoke in that time
which means that they have the most
reward to expect. They will be most
expecting of the greatest reward on the
day of judgment. Why? Because when a
person is expecting something great,
they stretch their neck out in
anticipation.
And so he says sallall.aii wasallam that
the people with the longest necks on the
day of judgment, those who are most
anticipating of great reward on the day
of judgment are the madun.
Well, that's great and fantastic if
you're a mued, but what about everybody
else? What about the people who are not
you know someone who is not a mued?
How can they possibly get that kind of
reward? Do they even have access to it?
In Medina, the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam only had how many?
two in Medina and also two in Mecca.
two in Medina
is
and
Abdahbi Maktum
Abdullah
Maktum
and also it's it's
mentioned his name as well as asbi
right these were his twoin and Mecca It
wasn't just whoever was available and 20
different people making a van. No, no.
The first thing the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam told someone when he would
appoint him as the imam of his
respective masjid, appoint a muadin who
does not take pay for his adan. This is
the first thing. The muadin is supposed
to be fixed just the im is supposed
to be fixed.
However, unfortunately the muadin
is not as
public, is not as renowned, is not as
front and center stage as the im.
Everyone wants to be the the im but not
everybody wants to be the mu.
But the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam has mentioned that if people
had any idea the reward that a person
has for
they would insist
on
alqur is drawing straws to
u to see who would make a then meaning
they would never give it up for anybody
else to make a then
and So
he asked the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam
that the gets all the reward.
What about us?
And so the prophet sallall.aii
said,
he said, "If you hear the making,
then repeat after him what he says,
and then make a salah upon
So here we want to unpack this first is
we repeat after the
except for
which is
and
these two we say what.
So he said to repeat after the repeat
after the not with him. So you repeat
after the
until he finishes. He said then make a
salah upon me.
This is a sunnah which is
vastly overlooked and almost forgotten
to so many people and that is that
rarely do people
they repeat after the and they even make
the dua after the adan but rarely will
you find people that make a salah upon
the prophet Sam
between the two but that is the sunnah
and the most
full form of a salah upon the prophet is
the same salah we make in our prayer
which is referred to as
the companion said.
[Silence]
And so when he taught the companions how
to make a salah upon him, he taught them
what
the same thing we say after.
So here when he says
repeat after them and then make a salah
upon me meaning what?
And then follow that up with
saying
[Silence]
He said, "For whoever says this
and then asks Allah for me,
there is a place in paradise that is of
the highest points of paradise that is
only fit for one person
and I am hopeful that that may be me. So
whoever makes this
dua for me after the adan and upon me
then
on the day of judgment I will be his
interceder meaning I will intercede on
his behalf
with Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala to lessen
his punishment to raise his level in
paradise to forgive his sins whatever it
may
And so now we have a plan. When we hear
the aden
right, we say what the is saying exactly
except for
we say
after this we make a salah upon the
prophet
the full salah.
[Silence]
What I just said right now is one of a
few different wordings of
there are a number of wordings of
they're found in Bkari Muslim and also
in
elsewhere
when a person prays they have to make
sure that they are saying exactly one of
those wordings. Anyone any one of those
wordings you can choose is correct but
it has to be one of those wordings.
When a person is finished saying that
then they make the dua
at at the end. That's the entire dua.
The addition that is often added in
is not a part of the narration. This is
an addition that people say. The
narration as is found in
is
to there.
After this
there is time between the adan and the
correct.
During this time
between the adan and the what should a
person be occupying himself with
okay asking Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
for forgiveness okay
[Arabic recitation]
who else
dua
Okay, you're on to something there. A
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam said
that whoever says as the says makes a
salah upon him and then makes this dua
whatever is between the and the
of dua is answered by Allah. This is a
time when dua is accepted by Allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala.
What does that mean? When we hear
narrations that say this, this is the
time when dua is accepted. Does that
mean dua is not accepted outside of
these times? No.
This means that dua outside of these
times or places or occasions,
it is hopeful that Allah will accept it.
But during these times, it is certain
that Allah will accept this dua during
these times under these conditions that
the prophet sallall.aii was mentions.
How many of us have problems in our
lives?
He's laughing. If I tell you about my
problems, you'll go and buy a piece of
rope. How many of us have problems in
our lives? Every single one of us,
right? to a point that we don't even
want to talk about it. We're tired of
talking about it actually. Right? How
many of us really thought, you know
what, this problem I can't crack it for
the next until this problem is is Allah
brings me a solution. I'm going to make
sure that I'm in the masid for all
prayers possible and between and I'm
going to make dua for this issue.
That's a solution, is it not? Yeah, it's
a solution. How many of us think that
way? I mean, it's nice to think, but
when is the last time you really came
into the masid or any masid and found
people in fervent dua between and when's
the last time?
Almost never. This is usually a time for
what? Chitchat, small talk. Hey, you're
getting fat, you're getting skinny. Hey,
how's this going on? How's that going
on? Oh, did you see what happened? Blah
blah blah blah blah. As a matter of
fact, if someone comes into the masid
and finds you making dua, almost
certainly they will come and interrupt
it so that they can talk about the
weather or talk about the football game
or talk about what Trump is doing or
what whoever is doing or talk about ICE
or talk about the news or talk about CNN
or talk about
This is what's killing us. It's killing
us
because what's the idea? The idea is
[Arabic recitation]
I need it. When has that time ever come?
Tell me. Am I saying anything new here?
We all know these. We all know them.
Few things that I'm saying here are new
to us. Most of us know that dua between
and is a time when dua is accepted. We
know this. And probably every time if we
know this when we come into the masjid
and that time comes between and
we that narration comes to mind and
we say you know I should make dua but
then we get that little whisper which is
what
inshallah I have five prayers to pray I
you know I'll make dua in the next one
in the next one in the next one in the
next one Tomorrow. Tomorrow. When did
tomorrow ever come? Has it ever come?
How many of us have tomorrow?
Tomorrow's in our lives that have yet to
come. 20 years have gone by. 30 years
have gone by. This is the game that a
shaitan plays. What is the game? Promise
me today. This is what he tells you.
Give me today and I promise you
tomorrow.
Right?
Give me today and I'll promise you
tomorrow.
And this is where we're going to the
point that let's say you came into the
masid and you found a person making dua
and it's between the adan and you come
to you know chitchat with him and
find him what
he's a little bit cold. He's not
responsive because he's obviously busy
with something which is his dua. Most
people would be highly what? Highly
offended.
You know, I'm here. We're supposed to
chitchat.
This is a masid. People come here for a
reason. What's the reason? To worship
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. How can you
be offended by someone who's doing
exactly what this whole structure was
built and designed for?
And so the point here is what the point
is many of us know these things. There
was a student
an Egyptian
student that was you know one of
our peers and he had mentioned that you
know he just had so many problems. He
had so many issues in his life and he
was starting to become a little bit
hopeless with all of these issues and he
couldn't really find a solution for
them. And so he said, "I decided to turn
to Allah,
especially just during that wasted,
squandered moments between adan and
so I took it upon myself to make fervent
dua." What is fervent dua? Your heart is
in it
and your tongue is following your heart.
fervent dua in those few minutes between
thean and the he said in a very short
time Allah gave me so much more than I
asked for that I became ashamed of
myself for asking for so much
the solution is there but a person may
look at it and say well it's only two
minutes left yeah what's two minutes.
You know, 2 minutes the average human
being in a western society spends six
months
waiting for red lights. Did you know
that
just those little that moment waiting
for the red light to turn green, you got
six months of your life there.
What could you have done in six months?
There's a lot that can happen in one
minute,
right?
You know, they say that even if a
person's head is cut off, they live for
an average of 7 to 12 seconds. That's a
long time,
right? You could do a lot in 12 seconds.
The point here is that these squandered
moments,
right? These squandered moments are the
reason we're losing our footing and our
battles with the shaitan.
Because of these few minutes, a minute
here, two minutes here, 3 minutes here,
a few of this. If you imagine someone
who budgeted their money in this way,
it's only two minutes. It's only one
minute. It's only three minutes. If they
budgeted their funds in this way, what
would happen? It would be in terrible
debt. Correct?
You have to look at your and say in that
exact same way.
And if you start to do these things,
right? You're not you're not doing that
anymore. From now on, I'm going to make
my dua at this time because it's a
sunnah and I know it's the sunnah,
right? People are going to find you
strange
because we live in a time where sanity
is
considered insanity because we live in
an insane world. The prophet sallall.aii
wasallam said
that Islam began what?
[Arabic recitation]
what?
strange amongst non-Muslims. It's a
strange even amongst the Muslim.
It doesn't mean that we have to be in
that situation. Doesn't mean that I'm
talking down to you or that I don't
know. We're all trying to find our way
out of the out of the sleep, out of the
misguidance slowly, little bit at a
time. We have that one sunnah. I say to
myself from now on those minutes between
and
my vow is to dedicate those to dua no
matter what.
Right. Talk before salah talk after but
during that time only dua unless there
is some issue that comes up that that
demands my attention. Right? You have
just taken one step
and made the shan take one step back in
your battle with him. And that is how
the the war is won. One battle at a
time, one step at a time. Okay. Other
than dua, what's another thing that the
prophet sallallahi wasallam said we
should do between and
anything else?
read Quran.
That's an interesting point.
The scholars mention
that what is the greatest type of
the best type of what is it? Reading the
Quran. Correct. But is reading the Quran
the best type of at every single moment
or time? No. It depends on the time and
place. If we say for instance, what's
the most virtuous
you know salah for instance making
that's the most virtuous thing to do in
the last third of the night. Correct.
Correct. What about if you have a guest
that needs your attention during that
last third? What becomes more virtuous?
making salah or tending to your guest,
right? Same thing here. Reading Quran in
general is the best. But specifically,
not between and not even before Jum. The
scholars mention before Jum a person
should occupy himself either with dua,
reading the Quran or salah.
But some of the scholars were asked how
about reading the books of before Jum.
The answer was that is discouraged
before Jum. Reading the books of now
because this is a time for either
reading the Quran, making dua or making
salah. Now the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam said
He said in a narration
between every twoan
there are two raqa.
Now he said it in a way to show that it
is strongly advisable
almost obligatory
but just a hair short of being waj.
So he said three times this
[Silence]
He repeated it three times. He said
between every two adan there are two
raqa
raqa between every two adan there are
two raqa
for whoever wants to. that statement at
the end for whoever wants to means what
meaning it's not obligatory but the way
that he said it it almost could be.
So
here we have an order.
Number one we repeat after the
number two we make a salah upon the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
Number three, we make the dua for
Number four, we make number five, we
spend the rest of our time making dua
until the Okay, what about ending at the
often times when people listen to the
they're usually silent.
that narration I just mentioned
between each two then what does that
mean? each two adan
between the adan and the
so the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam re
referred to the as what as an aden right
that's important that's going to come
into play in a moment often times we
hear that when the is being made people
don't usually say anything and then when
the and ends withahillahill.
Then you hear everybody start to say
something eitherall
orahill
or whatever people have.
None of this is necessarily the sunnah.
The sunnah is to repeat after the the
just you repeat it after the
exactly the same.
What about when the when the
says
You say
due to the generalities of the commands
in the narrations, the sunnah is to
repeat the after the just you
repeat the after the
only difference is that there is no and
dua after the there is between the
and the so whenever the is making the
the sunnah is to be repeating after him
as you would for the
and then when he
saysahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahillah
you merely sayahillahillah
just he does these are the rulings
of listening to the
and the etiquets of what takes place
between and
maybe next week we'll talk about the
etiquets of making the adan and the
[Arabic recitation]
before we wrap up. Are there any
questions about what we spoke about just
now? Now
we have this.
Does does it also apply to the two adan?
None. It applies to the adan that is
just before the that is a good question.
There are two adan for and some there
are two adan for in some if it is
needed. So these rulings do they apply
to both adan and the or only one aden
and the answer is they apply to the adan
that is just before the so if there are
two adans for the first is just a
notification you would repeat after the
but the salah and dua after this is
mostly specific to the real adan that is
the adan for salah which is the second
adan of those two. Now
we have two more here. We'll we'll we'll
end it with with these two.
[Arabic recitation]
just wanted to know if you come in
to the masid and someone is making
a dua or reading the Quran, can you say
salam to me? Very good. If someone is
preoccupied with making dua or reading
the Quran or what have you, is the
correct etiquette to say salam or not?
The answer is the correct etiquette if
it is an individual is to say salam. The
companions used to say salam to the
prophet while he was in salah in the
masid. So they would come in and find
him making salah anaf. If they
walked close enough by him they would
say assam to him and he would respond
with his hand this.
Wasam. If a person is reading Quran, yes
and you know if a person is making
dua yes you you convey but only if you
walk within their proximity that makes
it appropriate to make a salah. Not if
you walk in at the end of the masid and
bellow you know
you know startling everybody in the
masid. This was not the sun of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam. The
sunnah is only those whom you are in
their proximity or those who you make
contact with in a visual sense. If you
see someone all the way across the masid
and you you make eye contact, you greet
them. The prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
would greet with his hand and say
assalam to himself
this. And the person who receives
saysum
this. And this is how he used to
greet the women in the masid as well.
Wasallam. However, let's say we're in a
class this. It's a group thing. I'm
speaking, you're listening, or I'm
reciting Quran in the in the salah and
people are reading. Is it correct to
convey a salam now and interrupt that?
No. In this sense, you do not interrupt.
And this is something I think most
people you know can can kind of
understand by way of you know just
general etiquets. Okay, one more
question for the brother here in the
green polo shirt with the relatively
handsome features. Walaykum salam.
[Arabic recitation]
answers. So after ikama has been recited
is it advisable to refrain from talking
because sometimes you look at your
neighbor next to you and you
[Arabic recitation]
question actually because some people
would even be uncomfortable if I as the
im am going to lead the was called
and I for instance reminds people of
something or make some kind of
announcement between the and the or
speak they say you're not you shouldn't
speak between after the this is no
evidence for this anywhere in the sunnah
the companion companions used to speak
while the was being called while the
adan was being called after the between
the and this is all permissible however
is it a time to joke and chat and raise
our voices and interrupt and be unruly
no obviously we're getting ready for
salah so it should not you
know interrupt what
we're doing and it's it's a time to
definitely start to become a little bit
more serious listen to the direction
given by the im etc. But there is no
prohibition in doing so.
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]